[Music]
hey y'all
welcome this is crystal from crystal's
denim garden aka crystal's den
and i'm back here with you today last
time i was here i spoke about the five
mistakes i made as a beginner gardener
today i wanted to share six tips to get
your summer garden started
let's get into it so the first tip i
have is choosing your spot and
considering how much space you have to
work with
when choosing a spot make sure to choose
one that gets lots of good
sun most crops need about four to eight
hours of sun a day
so we want to make sure our spot can
accommodate that we also want to
consider how much like space we want to
use for gardening
some plants like tomatoes and oak grill
will grow really tall and bushy
other plants like squash and watermelon
are going to vine out really long
so just think about and consider how
much space you can have for your garden
and how much you can
give for your crops my second tip is
choosing
the crops that you want to grow this may
seem like a no-brainer but i wanted to
give a couple pieces of advice or
give a couple tips on uh some crops that
you could choose
one think about native plants so what's
native to your area
how can you create a nice ecosystem of
plants that you know can thrive where
you live
also think about companion planting
companion planting is something that i
like to do and that
i kind of that's kind of the way that i
situate my garden
um that's just when you plant plants
together that can
really benefit from each other and grow
well together and you keep ones that
don't grow too
well together far away some complaining
planting that i have going on right now
are my tomato and basil
which both enhance the flavor for each
other my sage and tomato sage helps the
growth of
the tomato i have some jalapeno with my
squash and cucumbers
and pumpkins because they help the they
help those vegetables not
develop root rot and then i have
geraniums and marigolds spread
throughout my garden
to kind of keep away different pests
since they don't like the smell
so all of that is um some examples of
companion planting and what i'm doing
and just kind of
something that you can consider as well
and then also make sure you have some
really great pollinators in the garden
some pollinators uh that i have going
are sunflowers echinacea
marigolds geraniums nasturtiums to name
a few
those pollinators are gonna help bring
the bees out and get that pollination
process
going and continued so just think about
that when you're choosing the vegetables
you want to grow
the third tip i give is think about the
medium that you want to grow your
vegetables in
what are you going to grow them in are
you going to do a container garden
are you going to be growing in the
ground are you going to be doing raised
beds
think about how you're going to grow all
of your crops and what that best looks
like for you when you're dwelling
that leads me to the soil choosing your
soil
when i was first starting out gardening
i
kind of thought i could use any old type
of soil i remember going and buying a
big bag of in-ground soil
and thinking i could put it in my raised
bed well
yeah that part of my raised bed did not
turn out so well
and i didn't get the best like result
with that because i put
in-ground soil in the raised bed um so
make sure you're getting the right soil
if it's if you're doing uh gardening in
the ground
you'll need like a soil amendment so
something to add nutrients to the soil
if you are doing containers or raised
beds you'll need the raised bed or
container soil
go to your local nursery let them help
you i've gone plenty of times to my
local nursery or
seed store ask them what's some really
good soil to use for this
different type of gardening that i'm
doing and they've been really helpful
so let that also be a way to help and
guide you too
fifth tip is getting a good watering
system going i like to have water in the
morning
or in the late evening try to avoid
watering in the middle of the day
especially if you live in a super hot
climate
because then the water is just going to
evaporate and your plants won't get that
good
the nutrient those the good nourishment
so get you a good watering schedule
figure out what's best for you
figure out what's best for your crops
how often they need to be water
and you know kind of like let that guide
you and then my sixth tip
is just have fun beloved don't give up
you can do this
there will be obstacles there will be
failures there will be things that go
wrong
it's okay it's part of the process it's
how we grow and learn
last year all my corn got destroyed by a
horrible wind
this year i have something eating my
cabbages and i keep losing cabbages
left and right and you know there will
probably be other stuff
happening too but it's part of the
process it's how we learn
is how we grow so don't give up keep the
course
you can do this you got this and
yeah have fun with it okay thank you so
much y'all for watching this i hope
those six tips helped you
and our you know encouragement for you
to get your summer garden started
um thank you again for watching this has
been crystal from crystal's denim garden
aka crystals din
and i can't wait to talk with you next
time happy gardening bye